isn't all this ridiculous
i created a monster
now i have to live with
div soon will be the only one to shine
i don't see how the city and
two dummies is monstrously help
you can complain kills me  to the
planet my dear
and to the survival planet to bend it
differently now it's not too
long that you have to sell it's him I
feel very different
yves saint
laurent challenge him varied approaches like that
working people  see by ear
sign the baster de beaumarchais leafs
then
the panels destroyed sometimes I close
my eyes
and offer myself I only see things
for your senses
I
stop I would like to stop
I can't
I think you  are the meaning
today
i was more competition this is
my drama